the Hollywood star has already given her
side of events to the court in Park City
Utah claiming she was the real victim in
that crash on the ski slopes in 2016.
but today it was retired optometrist
Terry sanderson's turn to take to the
stand and he had a very different story
of who was at fault
I just remember everything was great and
then I heard something I've never heard
of the ski resort and that was a blood
curdling scream
just I can't do it it was
and then
boom
he says the crash with Gwyneth Paltrow
had a huge impact on his health and life
including the end of his relationship I
knew she didn't buy into this she didn't
buy in to me not being the same person
and coming
into a relationship and
and I said I'm not sure I'm going to get
to back to normal again after the crash
with the oscar-winning actress he sends
an email to his daughter titled I'm
famous in cross-questioning he called
that misguided did you think it was cool
to collide with a celebrity absolutely
not
that is not who I am no do you ever
write that
ever tell anybody that I don't think it
came out in those words but I
remember that but
I
I think I was trying to communicate to
my kids with the end of Terry
sanderson's evidence the defense now
begins their case starting with ski
instructor Eric Christensen he'd been
teaching Paltrow some that day and who
denied he yelled at Mr Sanderson
He's a Bully to Mr Sanderson I was not
is that a ridiculous claim I I feel that
it is yes Terry Sanderson is seeking
damages of a minimum of three hundred
thousand dollars while Gwyneth Paltrow's
counterclaim is for one dollar Rachel
venables Sky News